kevin welcome to the home down podcast
hey man thanks for having me on
thanks for making the trip all the way
down here to in order to make this
happen so
super excited i love it down here do you
yeah really really cool
yeah coming from california you love it
in texas yeah yeah the heat is uh
typically dissuades a lot of people but
uh
for coming from perfect weather to uh
to
a little warm but yeah awesome yeah the
people
that's the main thing is the people yeah
yeah and the weather is of course
important but
i'm uh
i'm most excited about you guys you know
you and deke um deke was just on for the
second episode
and we covered a lot about his
background
about cls about the home dao and it's
good getting the other co-founder
to now be able to share a very similar
trajectory but from a new lens from a
new perspective right um
so this is super exciting i want to read
out kevin warren's background for you
guys
we'll be talking about solar energy epc
and so much more
so he's co-founder and ceo of cls
sustainable multinational solar
developer and epc with over 35 years of
energy experience specializing in cni
utility and community projects kevin has
originated designed and or engineered
over 155 megawatts of photovoltaic
installations ranging from small
commercial to utility scale projects
throughout texas cali colorado north
carolina illinois ohio florida
massachusetts maryland and dc
and cls most recently came on board as
developers of home dial which unifies
the best people idea systems and funding
and sustainability
bringing real world assets to web 3.
so you can find the cls sustainable.com
link in the bio below also kevin's
linkedin profile if you want to connect
with him there and all the home dial
links
kevin let's a blast off with
your journey and energy take us through
that
my journey in energy uh so
i went to school for electrical
engineering
and
coming out of that i
i
wanted to find
a space in in
either energy or just in the engineering
field that
i thought was on the forefront i wanted
something cutting edge something
that was on the upswing
um
so
through that i took off to colorado
northern colorado peonia
to um
go to solar energy international which
is kind of uh
just this
at that point it was just this
like kind of little
commune style school that
very few people attended because solar
energy was so expensive and so difficult
to uh to make
financial sense of
so
went up there i did my first training in
solar energy
came back to texas kind of uh
started tracking
what
exactly i wanted to do
uh got on a couple of rooftops through
my first solar panels and uh
figured a few things out um
and then met my
wife
um
here
and
one day i guess maybe a little while
after we started dating i said i
i wanted to go all in
um
in the solar field so we moved to
durango
and i think we talked about it earlier
and we
bought a 1964
airstream and gutted it and turned it
into you know a complete off-grid and we
found this little spot of land
on the river there and
yeah so i would commute up to sei
um for a week every month for the first
five months we were there to do my nab
step training
and
she would hang out
in our
in our trailer with our two cats and our
two dogs and uh not a much not a lot of
space but um
so from there
and you know you start you start
you start seeing where this is gonna go
as far as the the energy side of this
and
by the time i
started throwing actual
panels and making any money doing this
and
caveat
that it wasn't a lot of money you know
we still had to bartend on the weekends
and things like that there was no there
was no full-fledged
solar
career at that point it was it was
almost a hobby
uh that that you made money elsewhere
and um it was a labor of love for sure
uh and not a labor of you know financial
sense really
so
um
but
we could see that there was a wave
coming
module prices energy production prices
the way that we were producing energy
was starting to
drastically fall we were installing it
nine ten dollars a watt at one point and
now we're coming down to being able to
sell this stuff at about 450 and
obviously now you know we're down in the
cni utility space where we're down in
the dollar or 50 range and in certain
markets
and even lower elsewhere so
so i really thought that
maybe i was on the on the front
you know
uh
maybe on the front of of a big upswing
in this new
uh this newer
energy
production field
and
obviously we had
the
we had the feeling that
if we're going to make a lot of money
that's fine but we want to make money
and feel great about it
we have kids now but you know at that
point they were just a plan in the
future or maybe a thought
but whatever we did
i always say we because i'm my wife and
i gonna work as a team so
um
but whatever that venture was and just
wanted to make sure that uh
we left
we didn't make a lot of money
harming our children's future
so
came up with this idea of doing well by
doing good and uh
great and just rolled with it man and uh
it's been it's been like a 12-year
adventure in in the solar industry and
i've seen
um
i've seen
massive trade shows like like solar
power international and things like that
go from just you know 30 of us getting
drunk in vegas to now they're just
thousands of people there and it's just
grown
hundredfold since we were first in it
but
you know it's it's just been
uh
it's been it's been a wild ride and i
think we're finally at this point where
we've
set the table
to to a point that uh
some major major things can happen in
the next several years
we
got through
a lot of difficult times
and watched this entire field change so
it's exciting man but
and not so much of a nutshell that's my
that's my history
[Laughter]
in renewable energy
so yeah
i love when you're sharing there was
this um
there's a draw in a sense to solar at
such a like a young uh
places trajectory in such an early time
and then to sort of uh to actually get
up do installs
at when it wasn't even making that much
financial sense necessarily right and
then to see over time photovoltaic
efficiency increase um
to see the price of production decrease
to see the price per watt of energy
decrease so much
um and to see these conferences go from
30 of you guys to thousands
um
this is so cool that the time is totally
now and that you it's been a labor of
love
yeah yeah there there have been doubts
throughout
down the road uh yeah we
definitely
i have definitely doubted myself several
times in this industry but uh you know
we stuck with it and and uh
like you said the time is definitely now
uh i think we're definitely hitting the
precipice of
where it's just gonna make so much
financial sense in so many different
markets and um yeah i think
home down is only going to help that
you know explosion
yeah
let's hit this um from what you ended up
um building with deke so you guys built
uh cls sustainable
so d kind of gave us a nice uh
perspective on that we'll also link um
the episode two with deke in the bio of
this video and we'll link episode three
um in deke's video
so you guys can get a nice perspective
on cls from both of their angles
so then how did cls blossom and how
could you also like kind of recap it in
its essence sure yeah the uh
cls came about uh came to be
um
my wife was started living in a mountain
town and and thought uh let's let's get
back to our roots which was dallas fort
worth
and uh be around the family a little bit
more and uh obviously we were at the
point where we were gonna decide to have
kids and wanted them to be around
grandma grandpa's and
and also we moved back here
um
the texas market was
and as far as cni is concerned was just
not not exactly flourishing um
the energy cost in the state of texas is
very very low in most cases and
kind of difficult to make some of the
cni stuffed pencils so
um i was still
consulting back um colorado california
and nevada
new mexico arizona those markets and um
i ran across a a uh
they had they hired a headhunter
basically to to go out and look for
somebody to start a
commercial development team in
their
dekes residential firm which was circle
solar
um
and so
i went sat down with them
got a great vibe
i really felt like this was and uh
the team i wanted to work with and and
uh
the spot i wanted to be and
kind of turned out that that
circle l the the residential firm didn't
really want to dive that deep into
commercial
um
understanding how long these sales
cycles are and these
dev cycle into sales cycle into
uh construction cycles they you know
they're just really long processes and
uh
so
deak and i were like uh
so i mean
we had developed kind of a yang kind of
uh
you know situation with one another we
work perfectly together and we're just
like let's just go out and start our own
so
uh
not gonna lie we opened an office less
than a quarter mile away from circle l
and uh just
moved our uh we moved our laptops down
the road a little bit and uh and then
voila there was a cls sustainable but um
i think our i think our purpose was
with cls one
the uh the residential game is is a
pretty saturated
uh environment uh
and the cni game was something that had
just kind of and especially in texas i
mean it was just starting to creep up
so
anytime that i can
dive into something i i want to
i want to be on the forefront you know i
want to be an early adopter and i want
to
um
get skin in the game before
it becomes a convoluted mess
um that's really the only way i think
you can escalate yourself to to being
on the top level of professionals in
your field so
um
so
i mean whether it was smart or not uh
you know at that point in time we just
don't straight it
and um
we uh
we caught some traction early
and
um
quick
quick traction for a typical cni firm
and um you know through a couple of
megawatts pretty quickly
guys started flowing and um we were we
were trying to uh
navigate that and then covet hit and we
were like you know
all right well this gives us the time to
at least step back and and
organize processes procedures and and
you know kind of re-visualize exactly
how we want to take this leap because
in this industry in this industry if you
you've got you know two guys
in an office that
can develop and oversee building
a megawatt or two yeah
but if you really want to step up into
probably more than that uh you know
seven eight ten megawatts and now you've
got you've got to build a team yeah you
can't just be you yeah so i mean kova
gave us a
the ability to step back and and kind of
evaluate where we wanted to take cls
what the true vision was instead of just
such a rushed
frantic set the table and go
and that's kind of where we came up with
setting the table is let's let's
get every relationship possible put it
on the table let's let's
let's make sure that we're prepared
to take the next step
and um and yeah so i mean and then over
the last year we we've got our
manufacturers in place we've got our
direct contacts in place we've got all
of our installers all over the country
in place we've got our development
partners in place we've got our sales
team up in chicago in place we've got
everything in place now and then over
the last year it's just kind of
blossomed yeah we're super excited but
sweet
cool so
[Music]
oh you are already going into all these
components so let's
do that i love it i love it let's let's
unpack
the components so
um what is it like then
for um like a classical uh whether it's
a school or city factory etc
that wants to come on board cls what
does that process look like um so
as of right now so we've got
when we
we didn't want to oversee a bunch of
sales people um just simply because
that's just a hectic nature coming in
and out of our office so what we decided
we really wanted to do was set up a
sales office
or origination office um
sales in cni
and
um
yeah sales of cni is extremely difficult
um and
you have to have technicians you can't
just have closers and and people that
you know
set people up on an emotional sale
you've got to have like
really technical people that understand
the development of this or you can mess
up
25 years worth of financials for these
people and make yourself look very bad
very quickly so
um so we wanted was
originators and then from origination we
would funnel
into
a
a more organized and
um
experienced
dev team and then we would
pass that through our process
so
deek oversees the development side it
would go through deek's group
and then get a signature and it comes
over to my group for engineering
construction and and final build-outs
cool um so
yeah so as of right now we've got about
100 no what do we have 48 trained
originators around the country
and then but we have a group that has um
124
or so commercial sales guys that are
beginning that training process so yeah
it should should bloom
whoa
sweet okay so then the originators um
like start off the relationship right
yep so then um then what does it look
like then for them to begin getting
funneled into d and his team and then to
get funneled into you and your team and
to actually get the install the next gen
technologies how they pay it off over
time um yeah create that micro grid
there etc right so
they really just go out and seek people
that are looking for solutions
um
[Music]
a myriad of different solutions whatever
we can offer um but
they they know
they walk into a school
they just ask
you know
what can we help with you know on the
energy side what are your what is your
reasoning for for
looking into this um technology to begin
with
and once we figure that out now we can
really design
based on what they're looking for if
it's financial if it's just
environmental goals if it's a
combination of both now we really
understand what we're looking at and
then
we
get all the relevant information energy
bills energy contracts
long-term interval data
and
drop that into the development bucket
from the development bucket
they'll do all of the analysis and and
initial designs from there
um
the uh
and try to get an understanding of
different technologies that we can mesh
uh to uh to make this work um
was mentioning solar and chps kind of
primary right right solar chp obviously
um
ess
batteries and and things of that nature
but you know
we
we do send it to companies like gce and
things like that to analyze controls and
hvac and all that
as well
but yeah our bucket is typically going
to consist of the three major components
either solar chp or
uh ess or a combination of the three
and ess stands for again energy storage
solutions energy storage solutions cool
so batteries yeah okay cool
um
okay so then
um
does the so it's really tailored like
you said to the um to the actual client
themselves and what their needs are
um and then based on what their needs
are then there's a design of what the
next-gen technologies would be like at
their facility and to make sure the
financials would work out for energy
generation um how much um
uh that they would actually pay less per
month to then cover be covering the
principle of the construction um so so
then so let's yeah let's keep exploring
that the mechanism itself yeah and i i
think that's i think that's so important
to our process is tailoring it to the
client
because
so many companies will drop in and just
say this is what
we're good at so this is what the
solution is we really have so many
options um
and
[Music]
for
especially on the financial side
we can make things pencil in ways that
straight solar can't by adding these
other elements
so yeah it's very very important to us
that we
mold
all of these solutions into
something that fits each individual
client
yep
and then so then the
the process like i like the idea of
talking about it like a no-brainer and a
win-win-win so
how how is it then that um the
school muni factory etc has a
um
they're currently paying more for their
energy bill
to a utility right then they have a
specific um does they have a desire for
next-gen technologies whether it's
financial environmental mix of both etc
and then they're able to um have you
guys um assist them with the transition
the epc side of it the financial side of
it all of all of that stuff
and they're able to then over time
actually
pay less money per month instead of to
the utility they're paying um
towards the principle of the next gen
energy project that was constructed on
their property
and so then it becomes a
um
a no-brainer for them to make the
transition and to then own the renewable
technologies over time
oh sure yeah we
we produce energy at a
cheaper rate than anyone on the planet
right now in in the solar field we're uh
wow yeah there's there's it's really not
even much of a comparison so
in most cases
um and you know
we'll be
completely upfront and honest if it's
not a feasible project financially
feasible project if that's what it's all
about is financials then you know you
walk into a situation and you just say
that's not gonna be financially viable
um
but
the idea is obviously to save
significant money not just you know
pennies you're you're looking at
um
25-year projects 30-year financials that
uh you know
the these
modules you can produce for the next 25
to 30 years they'll produce longer than
that but they're actually warranted to
produce for 30.
so
the uh if your payback's eight years six
years five years four years now you've
got
you know
the
whatever 30 minus that payback year
you've got that worth of free energy so
it's uh
and then if you're looking at long-term
payouts as our
long-term leases long-term
ppas things like that then you know
it's not gonna be really financially
viable if you don't save you know ten to
fifteen percent off of your future
energy bills yep and uh i think we can
hit those numbers really easily
um average municipality or average
school systems probably gonna save
around
you know
1.5 to 2 million dollars
uh over the lifespan
cool so over the span of 25
or so years yeah wow and that's in um
savings based on energy expenditure
right
cool wow
cool um
and then they have the next-gen
technologies on the premises as well um
and it um it creates an energy
independence also which is nice
absolutely yeah
so there's not a reliance on drawing
from the utility which is great right
yeah there's so many core components to
this
this abundance of solar energy versus a
fossil fuel drawing from that right
right
yeah the uh the old
adage is you know
if if we ever stop drawing energy from
the sun we're all in much bigger trouble
yeah
that's great this is like
um
the uh in cosmology there's like a
kardashev scale of like civilizations on
how far advanced they become yeah and to
hit sort of the first big threshold
you have to
draw your energy from the local star
right
instead of from the local on earth
resources right and it makes sense
there's many futuristic ideas about
dyson spheres and all these other
different types of technologies that can
harvest even more power from the sun
sure yeah we're probably on the verge of
some of that but yeah it's cool because
now we're like hitting a cosmological
threshold of drawing energy from the sun
the star instead of from the fossil
fuels on the local right local planet
which was important in the transition
for the industrial revolution and all
the stuff we went through but now is the
time to make the transition into
getting the power from because the
technology is there and the technology
is is cheap enough and the technology is
understood the the biggest
the the biggest hurdle we have
transitioning to renewable energy is is
the the grid itself and and
upgrades to the grid
um
[Music]
massive upgrades are going to be
required in order for us to interconnect
enough of this
to uh to really make huge dents so i
think i think upgrading
our infrastructure next into
um
then installing
many more solar panels as many as we
possibly
can um but yeah i think that that's
i think that's definitely the next step
so
that's a really cool uh analogy
yeah
so
what's the uh efficiency up to now on
photovoltaics like 25 or something uh i
mean you have certain modules hidden
much higher than that but yeah i mean
anywhere from 22 to 28
and then potential to go up to 45 or
something so
theoretically yeah
and then supposedly some have
started approaching
you know that range but cool
nice
um
and then
the
um
so it so for example um many of the
um
the solar installations typically end up
happening in areas that get a lot more
uh frequency in sun right
so
um
have you have you guys noticed that
there's a tremendous amount of increased
uh
cells to cni in the southern part of the
united states versus the northern
not really interest so
the
the biggest driver
on the cni side is going to be
supply rate
electricity
so
[Music]
in the southern states you you're
we're sitting here in texas texas
a ton
of um
a ton of sun
a ton of natural gas
ton of oil
you've got lots of different
energy sources and the
that drives down the cost of energy
so your average supply rate here in
texas is going to be somewhere in that
4.8 to
6 and a half cents a kilowatt hour
but your average supply rate up in say
the northeast is going to be closer to
eight and a half to
you know up to 11.
your average supply rate in california
is going to be 15 and a half
um so interesting
so texas five cents approximately
kilowatt hour northeast 10 cents
approximately kilowatt hour california
15 cents yeah and sheer supply rate so
that's the biggest driver it's it's what
what
what's the avoided cost
so
when we install in texas we've got to
install at a very low
price
um
and then
california obviously
is
typically
much higher from a labor perspective
from
you know equipment perspective
but you can still make it pencil a
little bit better
um different states have different
incentives um illinois has a massive
incentive program that you can shave
you know three to four years of payback
off
damn you know yeah and um
uh same with maryland same with dc same
with these
other markets so
there are there are lots of
there are lots of variables um when it
comes to where to
where to build
you know and exactly the financial
interesting it's not just
more sun equals more solar definitely
not that's cool so i wish one of them
one of the big variables is is uh the
incentive programs that are a part of
those areas that's a big one incentives
and avoided costs are mostly the biggest
avoided cost what does that mean again
uh whatever the client is avoiding
paying for
electricity so
you're uh
if you're if you're paying five and a
half cents or you're paying seven and a
half cents and we can come in and
produce at four and a half oh
you've got a three cent avoided cost i
see okay so the delta
what they'll save right per kilowatt
hour
is avoided cost okay
so that's the main thing you guys want
to prove
cls wants to prove to the
to the
prospective customer that the
amount per kilowatt hour is going to be
a penny two three
less
as part of the right yeah right and you
know cni is such a different
world you know a lot a lot people think
emotionally about their homes and they
they
they say you know
you have a sales guy come in and be like
it's going to be a 10-year payback but
then you'll have these on here for 20
years and you won't pay anything and
they're just like
they they start thinking about their
home emotionally and and can be driven
into an emotional sale or an emotional
clothes
can't do that in cni you know you're
going to be sitting in front of boards
and you're going to go to the cfo and
you've got to make financial sense in
order for this to happen
so that is our responsibility first and
foremost is to prove that
this is a financially viable project
that when it hits the cfo's desk they're
going to look at it and say okay we're
going to
we're going to save x amount over the
next x years
and
and make it a financially feasible
situation for them so yeah that's the
first thing we have to prove yep
yeah
that's cool that's a big difference and
then also there
um
there's something about like when you go
for cni projects there's also a greater
like the epc itself has to scale
tremendously because you're not just
putting up um i don't know how many
average panels go up on a home
um 20
um yeah so you're probably looking 20 to
30 in texas um yeah and then on a
factory or school i mean what a thousand
two thousand um
on a factory
um probably closer to about
twenty five hundred yeah maybe three
thousand
um depending on the size uh schools
we're looking at probably fifteen
hundred or so that's so cool and then um
wow yeah so like production facilities
stuff like that uh but there's just like
warehouses you're looking at about 1200
yeah somewhere in that range
so yeah a lot more cool a lot more so
there's a lot more juice
flowing uh up on that rooftop than the
the typical house so you've got to have
some specialized
a specialized epc in a skilled epc and
to pull it off
and so then over time there's been like
an accruing of um
the partners that can do these processes
oh goodness yeah that's what that's why
i'm the mentioned earlier of setting the
table yeah let's go to this yeah we
really didn't want to get into this
[Music]
without
a significant amount of backing from
strategic partners
located all over the place
and highly skilled knowledgeable
partners um
shockingly and and not shockingly in
some cases but i mean i i didn't think
it was going to be this difficult to
find them
both from manufacturer direct contacts
you know we
we decided a long time ago that we we
can't use distributorships to
buy product and make this pencil for
hardly anyone on the cni side
so we
we order
you know manufacture direct products now
we have manufacturer direct
relationships and and setting that
portion of the table just a procurement
side was
was an absolute beating and uh really
thought it would be easier but uh so
when we talk about the p in epc the p is
the direct relationship with the
manufacturer direct relationship with
the manufacturer yeah our procurement
relationships exactly so you want to get
the solar panels
at as close to the cost where it's a
win-win for the producer right of it and
for you guys to then be able to uh sell
to right it's just like any other thing
where you know you've got you've got a
contractor that buys wholesale versus
you going to lowe's and buying your own
plants or something you know it's great
like it's uh it's just a significantly
different price
and making it a lot more plausible
through that relationship that you've
established with the procurement sure
because then it becomes easier for the
school of the factory to come on board
right and i i think it also just gives
them a little more ease of mind that
we've got
enough skin in the game for
manufacturers to deal with this directly
that's great you know yeah um to just
say that it's such a big deal yeah
they're like oh you guys know the
manufacturer directly that means when
your team's also serving uh servicing
over over the years that if you have any
questions if your people have any
questions you talk directly to the
manufacturers the people that make it
yeah yeah it does it does give a lot of
peace of mind and that was kind of an
unexpected reward of setting the table
with all these manufacturers
you know we sit down in a boardroom and
all of a sudden there's like oh that's
really impressive you guys are doing
directly to the manufacturer and we had
no idea that was even going to be a a
reward that came from that we we just
wanted to make sure we could get the
cost down low enough to
to
convince them that
to move forward uh on the financial side
so
uh but yeah that's just one part and
then of the table and then like i said
where we got to this
portion was the uh
construction side right so let's hit
that one a shocking amount of people do
not know how to build
cni
solar so it was
a it was
a lot of work to set up
our strategic partnerships around the
united states
we went from market to market
and
there were some swings and misses on our
part with uh certain partners and uh
you know and just kind of a scramble for
a little bit but you know we've got it
to the point where we've got uh
i think we've got 27 different uh
strategic partnerships in the united
states with solid constructors great
construction we've got um we've got two
national
construction firms to build some of our
biggest bigger stuff
uh on the construction side
um and then
like i said we've got our crews around
the nation
uh covering 35 states
that's big uh yeah and we we have a
partnership in hawaii but um that does
some island work caribbean work stuff
like that but
we don't
we kind of just
we don't we're not active in those areas
necessarily um if something comes along
then we send it over to them but uh so
are you so when you bring together the
um the e and the p let's uh the e p and
the c but when especially let's say the
um
is would you say that like deke and his
team on the table are doing the e side
of it in terms of the designs
no so they'll do preliminary designs
the uh once something goes to
construction then it comes to my desk
and my team okay cool yeah so
preliminary designs then to you and your
team on construction which then you guys
interface with the partners on the right
okay cool yeah so all construction
engineering actually all engineering
procurement construction all comes into
my
my my bucket so then you're sourcing
also through the manufacturer
partnership you would get
the let's say 2 000 panels for a factory
or school or whatnot
you would get them
and then you would have a preliminary uh
engineering and design visualization for
the construction partner
and then the construct would the
construction partner also sort of like
contribute to
um the sort of the field
visit to know for certain that those
designs are going to work in
implementation
and in construction right and
the design software that we use on
you know original online um
the first
designs
it's fairly accurate we we just come in
and clean things up at that point
what's the software that's used uh so we
use aurora which is a pretty well-known
um design software and then we use
helioscope which is probably the
most well-known sweet um
but then all the cat drawings all the
you know permitting plans all that stuff
that that comes later uh so
basically what will happen is we'll run
all of our financial models and our
production models off of
the helioscope or the aurora
layouts
then
get through the client saying yes
process the financial paperwork all of
that
but as soon as we get a a uh
either an mou or an or you know some
side of some sort of agreement then
it'll go into engineering on in mind my
side of the office basically
um cool and then we'll just clean
everything up uh
and make sure that everything's gonna
fit correctly make sure we don't have
any kind of uh
yeah make sure we don't have any like
snafu's with the fire department or you
know the ahs that and permitting and all
that so
we uh we deal with more that clean
everything up and then
we'll move into procurement around that
same time um
make sure that our
products are gonna land inside of the a
weak time or something like that if we
need a crane to go up if we need storage
there we can you know coordinate all
that
and then uh
coordinate with our uh so crazy with our
construction yeah yeah green cranes are
fun yeah so you see some so sometimes
you're um
the best way if not
always the best way to actually lift
them
um up so you have to store them securely
and then you have to raise them to the
roof right
and typically that's best with what
storage containers
uh for the storage that are secure and
then for raising them up um is through
just cranes that are maybe not the same
ones that we see for
the big skyscrapers but cranes that are
kind of more like mini cranes like 100
foot cranes yeah something like that but
earn
100 foot booms and then they just drop
down but like uh or 60 foot booms but
um
it doesn't always require crane but
sometimes it does and it's a little more
coordination because wind and things of
that nature but uh
but typically
just a sky track's gonna load it up but
like we have a project down the road uh
going on that has a
has a 12 foot pair put wall
it's a really high private wall we can't
just put a sky lift over it and unload
so we have to get a crane and drop it
down
so
[Music]
but
yeah it's uh
it's never a dull moment on the
construction side yeah that's so for
sure i love that yeah
i love getting into um how do you do
most of the time yeah
yeah it's not it's not always uh
rainbows and unicorns of course yeah
yeah
yeah so the site visits are so important
to make sure that all of the
incredibly important incredibly
important so yeah we'll get our
strategic partners to go ahead and
uh do that but
under our terms we have we have our
intake forms that they need to
send to us
on the site visit and if there's
anything on the structural side that
might be
even remotely uh
iffy then we'll send our structural to
site to do a structural review cool
it's really it's really fun um just
feeling like you said this table um
and how you guys even after your first
couple megawatt projects that you still
um had to like take a step back
and like analyze the table um
and
that
in doing so you could set up all of
these components in a greater um
with greater scalability um and with
greater relationships right and now you
said
27
uh partners across 35 states to
your ability to be able to right
construct
that's really really cool trusted after
several hit and misses too i like that
yeah cause it does it does take that
like adapt adaptive side that's very
biological also yeah i mean construction
it it does and but
construction especially this
construction uh which is
not a new commodity but it's relatively
unknown relatively new you know
there's
you're gonna have to have
thick skin and
learn how to fail and say i'm sorry on a
couple of occasions and then just make
it right yeah uh and so we had to go
through that those growing pains were
[Music]
you know prevalent and and there they
weren't
always the greatest of uh of times but
no i mean i i think it's i think it's
good to have a um
i i think that has earned us a lot of
respect too because we're really open
with the fact that we we have not been
you know
uh that we've been knocked down a couple
of times we had to find the right people
uh to do these jobs
and um
and now that we
we're there it's uh
it makes my life a lot easier a lot a
lot less anxiety yeah
so then what um
what is this like when
uh you have the procurement then of
let's say um 2000 or so panels and then
you have the construction of it how give
us an also an idea of um
an approximate time scale for a project
like that in its like most let's say
average but also it's increasing in its
speed because of all these pieces on the
table becoming more optimized sure
i mean
at the end of the day uh some of these
larger
some of the mid mid-range you know
megawatt
megawatt's probably gonna take two or
three months to complete
um
[Music]
from the
both the dc side which is going to be
your your
just your racking
your
modules going down
and your strings being strung together
on your modules and running that conduit
up to the
inverters which can be your ac side uh
there's a little more
between the two yeah typically about two
to three months
somewhere wow even just that bit like
created a new little cambrian explosion
of interest
it's so cool bro so
um
by the way is there approximately a is
approximately a megawatt of solar is
there an approximate to how many panels
that would equate to
uh right now
you're looking at probably you're
looking about 2500. okay 2500. sweet
i mean kind of on average with 400 watt
panels so i mean anywhere in that 2000
to 2500 range and about 400 per panel
400 watts per panel yeah okay
generative that's pretty good for per
panel wow yeah the the first the first
solar panel i ever went on
was
these panels are like half the weight
and producing you know
six times the energy so damn that's so
cool to hear about it because we're only
usually only focused on like moore's law
and transistors and sometimes in biology
we'll be taught about oh yeah well
actually the speed at uh sequencing is
also decreasing and cost the sequence is
decreasing um but hearing it in
renewables is awesome yeah yeah the uh
the technology boom has just been
kind of unbelievable to watch especially
over the last several years these
modules just keep getting you know
uh higher rating and higher ratings and
uh i mean we've got 541 modules out
there they're not
typically ideal for
cni
um
but
yeah and it's it won't be long before
you know we've got them uh like
a single kw and inside of one module
that's so cool yeah it's gonna be that's
gonna be weird that's great bro
okay so
um
so it's interesting when you started
sharing this
so much began
coming up as threats to pull on but so
you have a to install a megawatt of
solar you have about 2500 panels and
then
you have okay so the mounting goes up
first
you have all this it's usually is it
steel or what is the aluminum aluminum
because that's so much less in weight
right right aluminum mounting
and then um you have the panels that go
on top of the aluminum mounting but even
before that you run the actual uh all
the wirings that are needed but until
after the the
you mount the panels first right and
then you do the wiring right
interesting
um and so then the sole the panels
themselves are receiving dc locally and
then that's then that an inverter is
converted to ac right into the school or
the factory or whatever right
so then okay so those are the primary
innocence components mounting panels
taking the dc primary components racking
modules
inverters racking modules inverters
there it is you heard it here
i love it yeah i love it where
i can i can feel the sustainability
ecosystem and the homedow ecosystem
learning about this and it feels really
good
yeah yeah i mean it's it's a uh
i think we had touched on this earlier
that uh us being a part of
the home dial is uh
i'm going to have to learn a lot more
about the home dial ecosystem
and i'm hoping that we can you know
uh be available and that's really what
we want to do through this is be
available to
you know share our knowledge on on
our expertise
and and learn more about the the home
dot ecosystem as well so let's let's um
let's play on this because this is a
good transition into it so
so then
um
what will it look like let's say um
with let's say the streamlining let's
say that we really knock out um the
integration of web 3 with uh
sustainability assets
and then we just create uh
just a super facilitation of funding
into
the epc scaling
so how would that affect cls
oh i mean tremendously and
on the epc side maybe not as much as the
the development side the uh i mean
obviously they they go hand in hand but
the
on the development side yeah but our uh
the epc is always going to be a part of
the development but they're going to
deal with the financials a little bit
more and try to trying to to find funds
um
from
you know the majority of this is funded
by private equity already
um
and
the hoops and the red tape from private
equity
is uh
is something that is is uh hindered
um
the
pri the the non-profit
uh
aspect of you know non-profit entities
uh
schools municipalities things like that
things that
seem to be very very difficult to get
through private equity this is going to
open up a lot more freedom
to bring extremely financially viable
projects into
the home dial
into the home dial but
that are
cost
way too much to get into
the uh the private equity side
private equity money is very very
expensive
so
because that money is so expensive
it really negates a lot of the positive
financial liability of these projects
if you have this funding mechanism that
that like homedow then
now we've got
access to
easier cheaper free-flowing money yes
that doesn't have the red tape that
doesn't have the red flags that doesn't
have the high interest rates that
doesn't have all of that yeah
all of these things that hinder us from
being able to make
projects pencil and pencil well yeah so
oh that's so cool
now i i see this feel the streamlining
more yeah yeah and i think you know
d gandy and i have talked about this a
lot about just i mean if you
we've always you know we've got several
like home offices and things like that
that we deal with that that are always
looking for projects always looking for
projects always looking for projects but
have this is the irr we need this is how
much this money is going to cost all
that
we're viewing home dao as a massive
community
home office yeah that that's cool that
the the money isn't
expensive the money is
free-flowing all we have to do is
provide the oversight and the financial
viability of these projects yeah
that's so cool so yeah it's
incredibly exciting on our side and
we're just one developer exactly yeah
i mean
as the
like you say the ecosystem starts to
grow and other development firms and and
people that see
exactly what's happening here
it's uh
sky's the limit yeah
cool so there's with the existing um
old old money there is there's a bit the
red tape um red flags these things are
they inhibit and create friction in a
sense with this process and then the
let's say the web 3 and the tokenomics
the smart contracts the blockchain model
enables a more fluid less red tapey
as much as possible uh yeah frictionless
a process for developers from all around
the world to bring on
because you guys already have if you
want to say the know-how
you have the know-how of
installing the
uh
the next-gen energy assets um so you
have the know-how of the who's
interested and getting it done
and then just the funding mechanism
itself is then
yeah in websites i would see i would
even add you say who's interested
and into the construction portion but i
would i put
in the middle there i would be we
knowing who's interested
the ability to prove the value
of it
and then build it and the funding right
that's cool yeah the viability yeah
exactly yeah we were talking about that
and visualizing it as vetting um in
essence the vetting process yeah the
vetting process is uh
exact
interesting
man this is so good okay um yeah let's
uh let's come let's come to a close here
soon okay um
yeah and i'll be on again so exactly
yeah we can do another hour totally
later that this is this is the beauty of
the home dao uh podcast and ecosystem
um is that we have like the first round
gets to cover a lot of the like the
history and the existing um the
like cls sustainable and and then all
that we're doing with home dao
uh is still in it's like kind of it's
nascent like stages of birthing the
ecosystem so it's still it's still a
little like
fresh and new but then
when the second round drops it's gonna
be a lot more oh my gosh we're actually
have implemented this and this is
succeeding yeah that's the exciting part
because we're gonna move from
background and getting to know one
another like
you know
we've just met um
but
we're going to start moving into the
growth phase
of homedaw
and
the
the analysis and the discussion of the
future and that's that's the exciting
part that's that's what i'm looking
forward to i don't i don't want to just
sit around and talk about what we've
done yeah i want to talk about where
we're going exactly and what we're going
to do yeah and uh so yeah so the future
conversations will be
directed towards that and that's super
exciting and it's crazy because by that
point there will have been
um already like potentially deployment
across multiple chains nft drops
people that actually have home tokens
yeah
energy assets that are being built
through the home dao ecosystem right and
that's the sky's the limit like yeah and
i mean like
the americas and africa and europe and
asia all coming online with this
mechanism and developers coming on board
from those continents right um
that's cool i know we'll be doing this
on stage and at seminars with
token holders you know like that's so
cool that's the part that's awesome like
what's happening is awesome you know the
um
we look back at what we've done in this
industry and we still look at it it's
just you know
grinding you know or just this is the
way we've chose
this is the
direction we've chose you know and
to us it's not
always work but technically it is it's
our job and we don't look at it as
anything special
um
we look at the future of what can happen
with hometown we're like oh that's
that's special and we
we can't wait to start discussing you
know more of that
but
i'm looking forward to it almost like
the the past um
where renewables began birthing and uh
fossil fuels sort of like ended up
decreasing their um kind of their their
grasp on the energy systems um
that it was it was a little bit like
it kind of had a little bit of roughness
in a sense to the birthing of the
renewables it was very rough i was there
yeah i mean a lot of it i was there like
it was it was incredibly rough yeah um
yeah the uh
what's happened over the past 10 years
in the renewable industry is uh
is
what
any one of us that was in it 10 years
ago
the most we could have hoped for a dream
for
uh if that was the direction we were
taking our lives that's what we were
dedicating our lives to it was renewable
energy
10 years ago
we couldn't have scripted it much better
and it's cool because now we did we
scripted it perfectly this whole movie
of the universe is just so beautiful and
the way it's expressing locally on earth
um and then this other the other
component to that is as renewable sort
of birth the models of how it would get
executed is kind of still like the old
central money model of the execution of
it right and now that also dies it's not
kind of it is
fully reliant right on that old
money model
and now the birth of the new
web 3 money model it's
yeah yeah
yeah this is and so we're here at the
beginning of that one you were there at
the beginning of the last one i told you
i told you
we discussed that on
you know
30 minutes ago or so when i get into
something
i want it to be at the forefront and
like that's why we're so excited about
what's happening here
is that we're on
the first wave we're early adopters in
this at this point so
uh yeah
i mean we're really excited about it
can't wait to come back on and discuss
more more of the future
uh than the past but yeah what a what a
profound story though about the past and
also about where we're going with all of
this
i love it this is this is why we do this
it acts like a magnet like this podcast
is like a magnet for people to get
involved in the ecosystem developers
people from web 3 right all of the good
stuff yeah and they're like
i want in because this is it we're
looking at looking forward to it i i
agree
yeah
people have been looking for something
that
really
their heart is sort of screaming
for
something that
serves people planet profit yeah in
essence and this is it like this is this
is the thing it is yeah yeah perfect
kevin thanks so much for coming on yeah
it's been a really cool first episode
together love it yeah love it love it
yeah thanks everyone for tuning in we're
super grateful for you guys watching
um you guys can find all the links in
the bio below to clsustainable.com
also kevin's linkedin if you want to
reach out all the home dow links the
homedow.com our twitter youtube you can
subscribe follow there also discord as
well if you want to join um one of the
best things you guys can do is actually
share this video if you guys found this
video to be a awesome resource
informative then take it and share it
among on social networks with friends
family etc um let's get the word out
there about home dao
and also
um you can like the video that helps the
algorithm you can subscribe to
home dao also simulation if you would
like the links down there
and that is all we love you so much
thanks for tuning in everyone
and super grateful much love